de vue 1975 matra à toulouse c'était une
antenne modeste mais efficace de la
société ou non intégrer notamment la
fameuse case à équipements d'ariane
c'est à dire en clair le cerveau de la
fusée une activité qui n'a d'ailleurs
connu aucun temps mort et qui va même
s'accroître encore dans ce premier
établissement matra avec le passage
d'ariane en service opérationnel cela
c'était pour l'historique de
l'implantation matra à toulouse
aujourd'hui en 1982 à moins d'un
kilomètre à vol d'oiseau des premiers
locaux toulousains de la société existe
un vaste ensemble tout nouvellement
créées sur 15 hectares dans la zone
industrielle du palais la matra a vu
plus grand en décentralisant
pratiquement la moitié de son secteur
espace désormais partagée entre vélizy
et toulouse les raisons essentielles du
choix de toulouse revirements sont liées
à l'implantation du cnes qui a des
moyens très importants et aussi notre
principal client au plan national
deuxièmement à l'installation sur
toulouse les moyens d'essai
d'environnement spatiale de la sauver
mais à
troisièmement à la richesse du potentiel
universitaire et technique grandes
écoles de la région toulousaine qui
offrent les meilleures garanties de
recrutement et d'emploi possibles pour
des fonctions techniques dans des
domaines de technologies de pointe les
emplois la courbe est nette depuis
quatre ans à ce propos
de 60 seulement en 1979 ils sont passés
à 370 aujourd'hui ils approcheront 455
82 pour 1985 on avance le chiffre de 600
emplois là au lieu des nouvelles
installations matra toulouse
c'est en fait la seule l'intégration la
salle blanche disait spécialistes cela à
cause des tenues spéciales qu'ils sont
en train d'y porter pour éviter toute
pollution de l'atmosphère
cette salle est en effet la plus grande
d'europe avec ses 75 m de longueur
ces 25 mètres de largeur et une hauteur
de dix mètres l'avons prévu pour la
génération 17 et actuels qui sont
échappés de plus en plus gros et nous
pensons bien pouvoir faire tout à
décennies jusqu'à jusqu'à 1990 et
satellite donc de la classe ariane 4 qui
sont des satellites qui font jusqu'à
huit mètres de haut qui ont des
diamètres de trois mètres 80 et donc il
nous fallait pour cela des salles qui
acceptent ces volumes des portes
d'entrée était très grande et aussi une
salle grande parce que nous avons
plusieurs programmes en parallèle
actuellement quatre programmes sont
assurées simultanément dans la salle
blanche salle dite de classe 100 milles
c'est à dire qu'il y a seulement cent
mille particules la pureté aux pieds
cubes alors qu'en atmosphère normale
dans un même volume ces particules que
nous respirons se comptent par millions
le plus urgent de ces programmes 7 cs
premier d'une série de cinq satellites
commerciaux de télécommunications
construit pour eutelsat
il doit être lancé en juillet prochain
par ariane un départ à ne pas manquer
car pour les concepteurs d'engins
spatiaux comme pour les automobilistes
il existe un bonus et un malus et dans
les deux cas les sommes sont lourdes en
rapport avec le coût d'un tel satellite
qui est de 100 milliards de centimes
le deuxième programme nous
en cours et est une expérience
scientifique pour aussi pour les arts
qui s'appelle phoque est faux c'est fait
object caméra qui est une espérance
entités que l'on place dans la dans le
space telescope de la nasa et qui sera
lancée avec un navette spatiale
américaine
ça ça ira sur le fameux télescope
orbital
annonce le depuis quelque temps et qui
s'avançait par les américains passent
depuis qu'amélie absolument et c'est ce
télescope avec lequel nous espérons
remonter aux origines du monde puisque
il aura des performances absolument
inédite puisque nous sommes au dessus de
l'atmosphère
nous avons et moyens qui seront exposés
le troisième programme s'est elle est
comme un loup matra est le maître
d'oeuvre pour le compte de la direction
générale des télécommunications
il sera lancé en juillet 1983 enfin
autre programme en cours à toulouse les
équipements de prise de vue en h hervé
haute résolution dans le visible qui
permettront de satellites spot lancée en
1984 d'observer à 800 kilomètres
d'altitude des secteurs de notre planète
ne dépassant pas dix mètres de côté
voilà pour ce qui concerne la salle
d'intégration quand tu auras dôme de 13
mètres de diamètre et à la tour de 70
mètres de haut qui apparaissent de façon
très visible au dessus des bâtiments de
matra ils serviront à tester au sol la
fiabilité des antennes de satellites
avant leur mise en orbite
voilà donc ce qui aujourd'hui mettre à
toulouse et la question peut se poser de
savoir si l'on va vers une
décentralisation totale de tout le
secteur espace de la société et
décentralisation de la partie production
d'équipements avec les partis
technologiques associés n'est concevable
que dans la mesure où notre plan de
charge spatiale offre toutes garanties
au niveau de ce set de cette activité
en ce qui concerne la direction générale
c'est un problème qui actuellement est
considéré au niveau de la société
mais il ya lieu de rappeler que notre
activité est fortement tournée vers des
activités internationales nécessite des
contacts fréquents avec les ministères
et les administrations compétentes qui
jusqu'à présent sont plutôt en région
parisienne